so trieb tagein numero zwei waren
gestern abend noch bis 7 uhr unterwegs
bisschen gefeiert dem entsprechenden
heute ausschlafen die waren nämlich
gestern morgen so fertig also heute
morgen letzte nacht durchgemacht
dann muss mir diese nacht ein bisschen
schlaf als eine von sieben bis circa 15
uhr geschlafen dann haben wir ein
bisschen frisch gemacht fit gemacht und
wir haben platz 17 uhr und 20 uhr geht
es los in die stadt werden jetzt ein
kleines training reinhängen
da die kamera mitnehmen fläche eine
kleine teilchen training machen danach
geht es dann wieder an einen anderen ort
um das video zu schneiden und
hochzuladen ich hoffe das klappt heute
auch wenn das sieht dann hat es geklappt
aber weiter in berlin
blauer himmel die sonne scheint nicht zu
warm
kein wind ich kenne mich so ein kleinen
outdoor spielplatz / sportplatz auto
dimmen oder so an der yorckstraße darf
haben wir gleich mit der s bahn hin und
werden ein bisschen trainieren
die afghanen allerdings die bdsv jokus
im backstage immerhin von ter stegen 19
dies ist nach resort disney dis mal
bitte was macht ein kam mit kardinal
eddy cue man lange bis jetzt auf dem
spielplatz neben euch schon mal gezeigt
und wir machen jetzt die angekündigte
change und zwar lautete wie folgt
beschreiben wenn mein kopf egal die
laute befolgt 50 klimmzüge 103 mit
liegestütze gehen zeige ich euch gleich
nochmal bitte da macht mir die finger
einfach so zusammen mit meinen händen
und von ford hat und diamanten so 100
tipps also 50 klimmzüge 103 mit
liegestütze 100 tipps und 100 kniebeugen
dass die challenge in so kurzer zeit wie
möglich wenn ihr laptop hat macht die
gerne mit und schickt mir ein video als
antwort auf das hier oder als
persönliche nachricht aber meist als
video antwort falls das
david alaba wird zu das war fabrik um
kleine gesamten mama panasonic ev im pub
johannes dsw ev bvdm davon gab menowin
fröhlich und training 1 30 32
von den damals nicht alle geschafft ich
sonst alles fertig als echten richtig
richtig internetworld probiere gerne mal
aus natürlich willst du jetzt wieder
welche geben die sagen es ist ein zehn
jahre alt und machen die 20.000
freihändige liebe stützen in einer
minute aber wird gehen die gar nichts
machen naja wie bock habt dann prost die
antwort heißt es geht oder makler
youtube sie auch immer ein typischer ich
mag sie wir begeben uns jetzt noch mal
die ist wohl das video schneiden werden
die 80 nicht 19 uhr hat nur eine
farblose torstraße jetzt ist es sechs
nach 76 nach 19 uhr an wir haben uns
jetzt taxi genommen manchmal gepackt
hätten ein bisschen ärgerlich aber meine
eigene schulden muss jetzt auch
geradestehen
das ist immer eine halbe stunde und dann
können wir öffentlich schneiden bgv
im pater johannes b